got a news flash for you bozos the card
game is back on sale oh my God the
original edition of the card game some
of our favorite questions right here got
about 50 or so of them sold a bunch of
them put them on the shelf for a little
while now we're doing one final run of
the original series one last job baby
it's a good good time to get hammered
with your friends and find out at the
people that you know and that you love
are garbage so do yourself a favor the
link is in the description pick up a
pack today because they're gonna go
quick oh yeah and that ain't it tubby we
got Road dates baby we got two shows in
Atlanta coming up in November then we're
going to Charlotte North Carolina if
you're in the area get those tickets for
that we got two in Philly that are sold
out we got one left in Providence Rhode
Island those tickies are moving we got
one left in Boston that is for sure
gonna sell out get those tickets we won
a party see you there here welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage day three I'm your
host James Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
Antonio's basement she just went out to
Home Depot bought a bunch of pumpkins
and a pellet gun okay in case the
neighbors kids start to get cute you'll
be right in the eyeball okay my cows is
coming at you from across today funnier
the third time CEO are you garbage he's
an international businessman he's not to
be trifled in the boardroom or the
bedroom give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan Hey gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes over there and then
if you go to YouTube we got a full video
over there in 4k I don't want to add and
those numbers are true to rope cooking
almost at 100K get us to 100K hit the
Subscribe yeah even if listen if you're
out there and you're a listener and
there's a bunch of you just the
listeners on iTunes I see those numbers
every week dude there's a lot of use
just go subscribe get the numbers let's
go what are we doing let's get that cool
plaque in here yeah melt it down make a
cross out of it
I'll be rocking my YouTube chain go
werewolf Silver Bullet style uh and then
obviously the greatest goddamn website
of all time which is baby
's over there doing all right check out
patreon.com are you garbage you get
episodes of ayg every week again then
every week you also get a [ __ ] hard
feelings that's the 10 homies are the
ones really making out like Bandits yeah
I've got a 20 level with a bunch of Vlog
stuff we do on the road we bring new guy
Luke he shoots everything we're doing a
bunch of that stuff we gotta fit down
level check the [ __ ] out yeah a lot of
value over there for your dollar sure
bang for your buck and in these Economic
Times who couldn't use a value sure you
know what I mean giving it back to the
people yes how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good he
works the ones and twos he crosses the
t's he dots the eyes he's my best pal
T-Bone McMuffin Toby McMullen everybody
what's up dudes what up Tebow you two
against each yeah how can you have two
best Pals well I do oh wait you believe
him when he talks
I'd sell the both of you he told me that
was a new shirt earlier today this is my
Best gal this is my wife
they're both who was amen and sister I
do have a new one of these you saw it it
almost got ruined by uh some uh Wasabi
almonds
but I think I got the stain out sure
that's gonna be coming heavy bike did
you do yoga in that shirt no why because
the next little stretch down yeah that
neck did a little downward facing dog if
you catch my drift yeah the shirts gain
weight that's weird
bastards try to throw that shirt out he
said namaste
whoa look at you that was good stuff
there
[ __ ] Kippy Carlin over here okay oh
he needs the ponytail all right
and a little Cancer all right yeah so
what's cooking uh nothing just got back
from what I would argue I've been around
this I've been around this goddamn
country a lot you have a lot of State we
all have over the past year a lot of
dates shout out to everybody coming out
the middle uh middle class famous tour
we love you love yes
a lot of states have been about 50
cities or so in the past 18 months to a
year whatever that is 50 shows for
whatever
um trashiest City I've ever been to I
know what you're going with Niagara
Falls New York
Machi let me tell you the Townley forgot
about it
what the [ __ ] man it's rough up there
tell Canada to take it the only thing
and we did go off a little we did go a
little off season but I can't foresee a
big big change when is that in season I
guess in the summer yeah I guess can you
swim in it what no it's not shotgun
Falls
we're talking heavy bike rapids oh
really I mean not Rapids but yeah we got
on a boat went in and made a miss you
did yeah wow a little scared I was a
little I mean what are you not going to
do it's the only thing to do you see the
whole it takes 10 seconds you should
have ran a helicopter and fly around
there I think in class they did have
that but it was a rinky dink Chopper not
going with that dude a couple drops of
water hit that Blade the wind changes
the wrong direction next thing you know
you're [ __ ] good feeling it's like
the dunk tank ends up in China no way
whatever that thing is not doing it um
yeah man we were up there for a friend's
wedding and it was like two hours away
we're like you know what I'm never gonna
cut I went as a kid
my wife's like I haven't seen it I was
like well we're never gonna [ __ ] be
up here again that town was a little
slow
yeah I mean that's you know they were
they were a little slow that's Upstate
you know that's true slower Pace slower
Pace yeah yeah but I mean dude I waited
an hour for breakfast
at at a diner up there best breakfast I
ever had in my life there you go they're
taking time putting love into it you
know where I ate when I was at Niagara
Falls the Rainforest Cafe no yeah there
was a cheetah was my waiter
get these goddamn butterflies
I had that safari hat on it yeah moss in
My Soup
what store it was closed I wanted the
rainforest cat you don't know the
rainforest it's like a Hollywood uh the
hardware there's a hard rock up there
wow yeah it's like that it's not good
fully you haven't you do not understand
how trashy this [ __ ] is it's covered in
animatronic fake animals and and they do
it up with like fake fake Foley yeah
[ __ ] you know like Dave and Buster's is
like Hey we're the sports theirs is and
like you're in the jungle like the band
that uh uh Chuck E cheese like those
guys sure but a little more adult it's
like you know it's like you're on a
movie set or something not a good movie
Set independent movie Set porn you're on
a porn shoot
oh the tiger fries uh yeah stuff like
that we know we didn't go it was closed
um they got a hot it's just I mean the
whole the whole place is like and I was
told
the can the Canadian side's way better
yeah there's a lot more money over there
it's just you know
there wasn't even like a pizza shop or
nothing hmm
I was [ __ ] jammed up over there it's
just all around the town is this bad
t-shirts keychains can't get any crab
rangoon I'm out I know 25 bucks to get
on the old uh 25 beans to hop on 25 50
to hop on a mate in a mess they charge
it for the poncho now it came with it
okay yeah and how close did he get to
the fall you're you're in there baby
really soaked yeah yeah
isn't that dangerous I was nervous let
me ask you if he drove into the Falls
would have put the boat down is it
coming down that hard I look like I'm on
the [ __ ] Cornelia Marie I don't know
I guess yeah I mean it's yeah it's
[ __ ] it's one of the wonders of the
world isn't it is it salt water or fresh
water fresh but it says salt it's salt
there's something in there a little
stank on it it's probably so sweet no
it's really clean Canadians like fresh
[ __ ]
uh it's from and there's no place or
something there's no pool where you can
go swimming or something like that I
mean I'm sure you could swim further
away huh
yeah wow it's [ __ ] I mean it's and I
I went as a kid because we're trash we
were like well let's go another thing we
were up in Canada and we were like oh
we're up here let's take a look at it
dude we went to like Madame tussos
[ __ ] wax museum it's like times it's
like a really shitty Times Square Jesus
yeah it's bad there was like the weed
trucks Oh and the fake weed and stuff
it's a [ __ ] scene dude yeah where did
you eat
um we ate at a food truck Indian food
truck had a caddy roll two condos they
were fan [ __ ] day stick okay two of
those and then that night we found this
place wine on third which was their like
hip socialite you know it was a bar for
the most part but had a okay uh menu
who's working there Sesame Street
characters no no no no it's just proper
properly Minnie Mouse
good ahead of me dude this is the first
time I ever saw that we got the meat and
cheese plate as an appetizer it came out
with like 74 pounds of meat on it to the
point where I was like they knew there
was only like there's enough meat for
like 12 guys
there was I tried to count the number of
pieces of uh like pre-sliced Hormel
pepperoni that were on there it had to
be it was more than a bag it was like he
did one whole bag and I was like ah let
me top it off with another bag it was a
lot of priests like a whole pie with
that oh yeah which I've never seen on a
charcuterie board
it was right next to the jelly beans
all black ones all black licorice I
thought they were things
no but it was a fun trip you got I
recommend go seeing it is a thing but
you do it after 10 seconds you walk to
the falls you holy [ __ ] that's crazy you
hop on the elevator you go down you hop
on the boat there's an elevator you
gotta get down to Falls that's pretty
cool you get off you get on those boats
the elevator go through the Rocks no
it's supposed to be they built like a
just a standalone Tower huh
sure sure
a lot of fatties yeah take your Rascal
scooter over the falls watch me do a
flip bro uh
but then the whole thing takes under an
hour you get there you see you go holy
[ __ ] this is crazy you look you do your
picks you said
you go down you hop on the elevator the
boat comes every 15 minutes or so the
ride's only like 12 minutes you go in
there and you're done you're like all
right what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] else
we do you hit Madame tussos or Seneca
Casino folks did you go to the casino I
did it I figure we're going to you know
yeah
stay losing my money out there like a
gentleman save the rent money sure I
feel you but that's pretty sweet if you
get a chance go but it's trashy it's a
good time
hope that was all right everything I
would do the Grand Canyon I don't know
if I have any interest in Niagara Falls
especially after I saw your videos it
was like all right I mean it's pretty
cool I saw a video online you posted
something I didn't post nothing one of
these did you following my wife of
course we're friends on social media
certain chat groups certain Backpages
[Laughter]
um
yeah Grand Canyon would be fun it's one
of those things you're like I gotta do
if you're that closure like it'd be
weird to not [ __ ] do it Grand Canyon
is different that's real classy
classy what are you talking about
there's no Pizza Huts out there yeah
this isn't in the desert yeah there's no
pizzas in Niagara Falls either I want to
go on record this is the name she's old
I am oh you know when we flew to Vegas
uh with to to do the shows with Bert
shout out to Mr Chrysler shout out to
Burke grassler the best
um we Flew Over the Hoover Dam
you were sacked out or in an aisle or
something like that I got a good view of
that that thing looked impressive I
don't know how they dug that thing out
that was pretty sweet
just even like I was watching them build
a rest stop the other day I was [ __ ]
I was driving home from Niagara Falls it
was like
I'm like that oh someone put up all of
those being there's a crane putting out
like one beam and it took like nine
minutes and I'm like this is gonna be
here all week buddy [ __ ] wrap it up
let's go I need my Auntie Anne instead
trying to get some cologne oh yeah all
right but Gang This is a family episode
as you know as you know when you sign a
pretty old patreon there you can have a
question read on the air you ain't lying
got a bit of a backlog we promise we're
gonna get to all of them
and we will do that right now on Who
Wants to be oh you go
uh we got a couple of heaters uh let's
see
this one this is from Tucker first time
long time five dollar Bozo respect it
pump up the thing get the good stuff uh
is it garbage to keep the shoe box to
store your new shoes in
I do this I found myself doing this is
it a garbage to keep the shoe box to
keep yeah of course for a little while
you keep everything I've just gotten to
the point where I can break away from
like I just got a new iPhone I threw
that box out immediately but normally I
would keep that for a couple of months
that's dirtbagmented I kept my TV box
for like two three months I wasn't sure
the warranty the return but I didn't
know nothing you gotta you have to
[ __ ] catch me slipping all right yeah
we had we had a uh a Wolfgang Puck
pressure cooker uh that my aunt gave us
that she wanted the casino and we kept
that trashiest sentence ever said on
this show we kept that box
it was signed here
that was a kid's college fund what are
you gonna do here that Buckman had his
John Hancock on there you mean Wolfie
signed that yeah yeah Wolfgang Puck's
all right I don't mind them oh you're a
45 year old broad you love Wolfgang Puck
shout out to him it used to be Emerald
but he's kind of falling off a little
bit they love uh what's uh they love
Gordon too Ramsay hey get out of here
with that Euro trash [ __ ] [ __ ]
Wolfies Euro trash yeah but he's cool
Ramsay's the coolest he's counted
everybody kick rocks with that guy plus
we ate at one of his dumps down in AC K
putz who's great what are you talking
about no oh you're just saying that to
win the argument yeah all right fair
enough guys we've decided gerbil in my
mashed potatoes we used to send it into
foleyville early this episode
plus he wasn't even back there cooking
you don't know that could have been back
there I would have heard him actually
yeah
I always wonder why he hasn't got hit
I'm sure he's had to and what if that
would be they'd be showing that they'd
be really leaning on that no because
then that would open the floodgates for
people to start smacking him around
he goes into these small town starts
running his mouth
I saw one where they thought I think I
think it was in Jersey strip mall
and uh yeah what do you expect it was
what do you want from these people at a
uh they they
accused him of planting a mouse I know
exactly who you're talking man that one
dude was not having it yeah it was an
old black lady right it was it was an
all-black family in the restaurant The
one dude was no bueno yeah trying that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah it
was great food was probably delicious
he started poking his [ __ ] nose
around in there
um yeah but I keep I got I got a box of
three in the house right now shoes yeah
in the Box have you worn them no all
right you haven't worn them that's one
thing well the one's the wrong size they
got [ __ ] up the other one I'm just
kind of waiting on I have a I buy two if
I like a shoe I buy I replace it real
quick so I have it
this is a very funny conversation given
that the studio looks like an S and
lrgware
yeah shout out to Kelly R shout out to
Kelly Hearts that's a bunch of clothes
and [ __ ] shoes we literally we're
looking at an Amazon department store
heavy bike
heavy bike be doing the numbers on
resale on these things for everything
the garyvee in it man good stuff too man
shout out to him shout out he was the
man uh this one's from Mad you know what
he doesn't want I want to get involved
in I jump in a rope yeah he does the
weighted ones weighted ropes really
uh-huh
might do that for fat Court smashy in
there too pretty good uh-huh did you get
jump rope and uh I'm pretty good at it
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want to not
believe you but I'm I'm that's why I
wouldn't just randomly be like I want a
jumper I was you said that about golfing
I didn't believe it he's actually pretty
good yeah you just don't believe me is
what it is well you're a bozo what are
you talking about every time like I
didn't believe you but you're actually
good at that like you never played an
organized sport before yeah I did you're
a little squishy around the edges what
are you I'm terrible but I'm lying
yeah I don't lie I said I'm pretty good
at golf I was pretty I'm pretty good at
golf you were great at golf yeah
compared to a fat idiot like no I'm
kidding that was me
I don't know the gentleman that sounds
all right uh wait I was gonna ask you
what when you were a little kid they
roll in uh with um
Jump Rope for Heart was the organization
you didn't have that day no oh it was
great it was like half a day it was most
we're talking Double Dutch right that's
what I'm good at really no what are you
talking about
no way that I would never have the
[ __ ] gumption when I used to Double
Dutch when I used to see kids doing
double Jets and they did it well I was
like that looks like a magic trick I I
can't comprehend it crazy but we had
this this squad I don't know what they
were they were kids and obviously some
adults would come like once every couple
years or every year
it would take up it was elementary
school or maybe Middle School it would
take up most of the day until lunch okay
and then we had a couple clashes
afterwards but it was called jump rope
or heart and they would come in and we'd
all be in the gym
and they would do a bunch of
demonstrations about jumping rope
then you could buy jump ropes they'd
give you some some crappy ones you'd go
out on the floor and they'd show you how
to do it they did like a whole thing you
didn't do any of this stuff no really
can I get a goo gun jump rope for heart
they've raised 1.2 billion dollars since
1978. there you go it's a charity
organization there you go what's it for
uh it's just gonna give you a heart
transplant in a couple of months it just
says that they're the all caps Premier
annual event for elementary school and
middle schools with thousands of schools
and millions of kids participating
across the US every year you ever get
any everywhere really into something for
like two weeks
that's what Jump Rope for Heart did
everybody who had them for a couple
weeks then they just went out there yeah
that was big back then I feel everybody
was in and then you're like what are we
doing yeah how's everybody [ __ ]
jumping rope yeah [ __ ] sings for the
broads what are we doing here you got a
football there Tommy learn how to
[ __ ] you can't do those you're gonna
throw a tight spiral can you do the
Rocky
the pitter patter because I can just do
the like I can do it right there I'm
pretty good oh you can do that yeah yeah
yeah I mean my endurance isn't good I've
even got a little footwork yeah I got a
little bit of footwork I can do the
doubles I can cross up what yeah we have
to see this okay are you kidding me yeah
I mean I haven't done it in a while but
I'm sure I'm I would put any I would put
any amount of money I have that I could
still give me like five minutes I could
I beat you were only about 19 doubles
you're rolling about 19 on it I'm
willing to bet thirteen hundred dollars
taxes are a [ __ ] all right folks yeah
they are Kip how about that DraftKings
oh baby love that DraftKings how about
dropping a little quiche on the 60s this
season gang basketball is back do
yourself a favor get on DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NBA spend a little money
have a little fun they got all kinds of
crazy deals going on throw down a five
dollar bet you get up to 200 if your
team wins it's wild do yourself a favor
I like to bet in the 60s I like to bet
on the over I like a little parlay I
know T-Bone likes a parley I'm starting
to sweat just thinking about it do
yourself a favor and get on that
DraftKings yeah gang just go to
DraftKings Sportsbook app opt-in and
place a stepped up same game parlay
today it's easy peasy like the big man
said um Philly till I die I also dabble
in other teams if I see something that
tickles my fancy Dirtbag yeah come on I
like action baby I'm an action Jackson I
got five here ten here 500 there
whatever let's go let's go keep it
moving lay it in let's lay it baby
laying upstairs
uh with payouts bigger than ever
DraftKings sports book is where we go to
bet on the NBA in all sports uh download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app now use
promo code ayg make any five dollar bet
this week get 200 in free bets if your
team wins only at DraftKings Sportsbook
with promo code ayg minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details of course do it yeah
Kippy it's time for better help better
help best in a Biz the best in the biz
gang I get stuck on problems all the
time I get focused on the problem I get
hung up on it I sit there I dwell on it
I worry about it and I'm shooting you
straight here I'm telling you how my
brain works and it's no good but you
know what's crazy if you go on better
help they can help you to find the
solutions and to help figure the things
out for yourself so you move on from
things you get on with your life and you
keep going and you don't gotta wait in
some office you can do it all online and
if you're looking for a specialist that
you don't have in your your area guess
what better help can help you with that
yeah gang uh I recently signed up not
too long ago I was a big fan of talk
therapy for a long time hit a little bit
of a rough patch in the old ciparino
life he's real crazy I'm back at it but
like somebody who's healthy I'm working
on my problems there you go I roll
towards the big man I'm working on my
problems Yeah by giving them to me uh
gang it's easy peasy the communication's
great you can send messages you can meet
uh face to face like in on a zoom if you
want or privately or whatever's up for
you it's fantastic so if you're thinking
of giving therapy a try I highly
recommend it betterhelp is a great
option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online get
matched with a therapist after finding
out a brief survey and switch therapist
at any time which is easy peasy when you
want to join when you want a better when
sorry when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhealth.com garbage today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com garbage do it
uh yeah I wanted to do that the ones I I
loved them they used to give us were
like it was like a rope there was no
handle on it I don't think though maybe
there was plastic hand there was like
red white red white red oh those things
were awesome oh they were all right and
they were like B do you remember those
those things stung and got hit by it
when the older kids would whip you
[ __ ] whip
did you catch it in the back that in my
middle school that's all they became was
weapons the older kids would just chase
you around they'd fold them in half or
maybe fold them two times and then they
would just have this like and they were
like heavy plastic the plastic they were
like plastic chains that would just hit
constantly with endure the whipping
close your locker and just catch one of
them in the eyes like ah yeah they were
bad my brother stole one one time and it
was crazy like came home and I'm like
remember the stuff that was at school
that was only just lived at school and
then you're like he had one at home and
I was like where did you get it he was
showing me a gun dude yeah where did you
get this I stole one of them beautiful
uh burgundy kickballs one time oh yeah
oh man smell them I can hear them ah had
that thing pumped up to the max until
Patty found out made me go back and give
it back Really Got Me hemmed up dude
right at me ratted you out yeah if you
killed somebody and you went to Patty
what would she say
um
because a lot of that was
what's the reason I killed them crime of
passion
uh
uh road rage no one saw you're not sure
like there was no like you asked for
ranch they gave you blue cheese and they
saw red
hell gotta kill everybody in this
Denny's now
um I don't know if she would drop dime
on me
she might give me a little cash to get
out of town probably dye my hair
a blunt are you drawing more attention
to yourself I gotta get a nice tan
foreign
I buy you the Flesh of your suit they
had
uh I don't know what about the piece
would she uh would she
Road Ray if I was if I listen there's a
difference
My Generation if I was wrong
she wouldn't they wouldn't they wouldn't
back me up if it was something like Mom
I was in a jam I got hemmed up
she would she would be okay but my
generation ain't like yours parents were
like no
none of that why isn't Billy playing
you're not playing because you stink
yeah but that wasn't my generation I
mean that wasn't your family yeah I
don't know if that was really my
generation I think that was like a
little that that was if we're looking at
this generation as like the sprawling 20
years of a generation or whatever 15
years that was definitely the lower end
of mine okay my generation because I
remember hearing those like the
participation Trophy and [ __ ] that was
all that wasn't that wasn't me I
remember I remember hearing the jokes
about that [ __ ] which uh I still have
mine hanging up thanks Denise uh I don't
know she would my but you have a jump
rope trophy hanging up no I was kidding
I said participation trophy
um I don't know if she would
she would probably give me let me get a
head start for sure she wouldn't be
answering the door not answering the
phone and where are you going where am I
going down south to try to hide out in
Europe got that Interpol over there to
snag no that those the European you got
to get to what Swift to Switzerland or
who doesn't who doesn't transfer out
really in Russia [ __ ] that hey you crazy
that's nice
sharing a bunk bed with Snowden uh I
don't know Brazil right there's like
South America where did they get what's
his name
who was the Mac of McAfee he got caught
down there the virus guy from like
Guatemala or something there's like no
training dude that there's the
anti-protection yeah he was also in the
little uh yeah oh he did
allegedly I know the dog snagged
somebody down to Mexico the Estee Lauder
guy they got him down in Belize he was
trying to he was in Belize but he was
trying to get to somewhere or something
he couldn't get out of Belize because he
got into Belize all off bad paperwork I
just watched a documentary really yeah
playing on my Escape man
I go to Argentina
that's where the Nazis went at least for
a weekend
go ahead and open go ahead and all
inclusive for the week
gotta listen we've got Foley at the
brunch counter he was at the Hibachi
Table
he had Trim in nine shrimping his man I
got a list of seven non-extradition
countries to consider let's go all right
all right Morocco this is very this is
very patreon but I'm in not bad uh
Indonesia you go to Morocco I said not
bad yeah Indonesia no Morocco yeah Hong
Kong Indonesia Elegance or thumb where
Hong Kong
I'd have to become a Crime Boss down
there
down there I said aren't they down there
I don't think so over there whatever I
ain't going
personally they'd have they'd be chasing
you with dog catcher in that
I'd have to get in bed with the Yakuza
yeah and they ain't the Cub Scouts I can
tell you that that was very dangerous
I'm sorry
back to school with the widgets you're
gonna have to get the hell's a widget
you're gonna have to get in bed with the
attack or the concrete pours let me tell
you hey that's no walk in the park
I apologize Mr Dangerfield shout out to
Rob did I tell you the line I've been
listening to his old record and he said
his father-in-law got a pacemaker now
every time he sneezes the garage door
opens
that's good all right Hong Kong's out
Morocco maybe no I'm all Morocco yeah
Morocco is great yeah and also okay yeah
Morocco uh United Arab Emirates nope you
can have a lot of fun out there but I
don't think you can boom no booze you
can't hit women
plus those guys are all [ __ ] that
[ __ ] up uh where is it uh Bali or no
bali's all right that's not the UAE no
that's um
in Asia right is Bali in Asia yeah no
wherever these bozos like Antonio Brown
are going [ __ ] acting a fool they're
gonna get all this [ __ ] shut down
over there because you're always over
there doing stupid [ __ ] those guys don't
[ __ ] around I'll chop your hands off and
[ __ ] like that
[ __ ] fooling around at the pool
I'm telling you
[ __ ] execute you for a pool noodle
okay all right uh Andorra I don't even
know where that is oh uh yeah it's in
Chicago isn't it it's a restaurant
that's Andersonville he wasn't
connecting it to anything I'm glad you
gave him that much credit
the indoor is it the andoras
it's a whole country
really
man they really are making headlines huh
no kidding well laying low playing it
right the kind of place you want to be
that's very you want to be a place is
that named Chicago I don't know yeah I
got my feet up on a beach somewhere
there you go is it in the water
uh no clue uh and then the last one is
Qatar no Qatar you'd be building one of
the World Cup stadiums yeah no the [ __ ]
out of there yeah you got to go Morocco
Casablanca style yeah that's how you do
it they don't have extradition so you
could murder somebody here and go to and
how you and get there and if you get to
Morocco you're good
they don't have anything where they uh
well the problem is uh the Ken
deals I believe
they want you to have political leverage
but yeah it's like yeah it'll sell my
fat ass in a heartbeat
kidding me
or I could we can pick up move the whole
shop over there do it from a beach or
something got to pay off them a little
bit yeah I like payoffs Kickbacks that
whole kind of thing I'm in could we
figure out fake passports and all that
stuff I'm thinking about getting a EU
passport
oh yeah I'm thinking about getting a
German passport so you can just in case
I can [ __ ] I got a couple of
Associates that have multiple passports
in case the [ __ ] goes down huh yeah well
you can also go to countries certain
countries I believe I think with an EU
pass where you go to Cuba Cuba go back
you can go to Cuba now man I think they
shut it back down what the [ __ ] really
what are we doing and it was only only
you can only go there's only like eight
people that could go eight it was like
journalists no it was like eight
categories of people I knew a bunch of
dirt bags that went and hung out for a
couple of weeks over there
said it was awesome
uh no you can't go just to hang you have
to have a there's eight reasons it's
like journalists education medicine uh
pornography religious activities pina
coladas religious activity there you go
I'm going to church
I'm a Catholic for God's sakes I think
it's like more of a mission oh [ __ ] that
unless you do a Bad Boys 2 style roll in
covert Ops blow up the building come in
remote control cars with bombs see ya
Bing do it that way oh I was thinking
more like fast and furious six I didn't
see that one I tapped out after two how
about hopping on a Jet Blue flight out
of Miami all right let's do it still
like that huddle jumper do it like that
all right let's get back on track here
this one's from whack my wee-wee twenty
dollars if we get serious how y'all feel
about putting ice in orange juice I'm a
big fan first couple of sips good
because it's cold and it's not watered
down it needs well here's the thing
orange juice needs to be watered down a
little bit I got a curveball for you
you're nuts with that orange juice and
ice
put a little bit of club soda boom maybe
homemade Orangina
which might be my favorite beverage the
Orangina you have one really I I
exercise self-control I don't know yeah
everything oh self-control age trolley
that's a good thing yeah yeah try to
stay away from it uh I'm all right I
think it just Waters it down too quick
but I do like a nice cold it's like I
like the thickness I like the I like it
buddy you're preaching to the choir I
love an OJ a fresh squeezed OJ I can't
do the fresh squeeze though they don't
do them that much in New York anymore
but I mean New York has gone downhill
with the delis and the diners so so much
over the last 15 years
but back in the day when I lived up here
the first time when I was banging on the
Upper East Side there was there was
unbelievable delis
a bodegas on every corner and they would
have the things outside they were always
in the corner and they went around they
had the fruit they had the flowers they
had a guy out there and every morning
they would put out these little like
bangers of fresh squeezed orange juice
with the with the with the orange tops
sure they'd be packed in ice oh man grab
one of those
so good so so good yeah but you were
yelling at me for drinking one a couple
weeks ago at the airport because they're
no good for you it's all sugar yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah your body can't process
the sugar
I believe it needs the fiber everybody
says that my body can process anything
that's my problem
have you looked at your butt this is fat
cord have you looked at your body it can
process it though I can eat a license
plate and get it in me I guess if that's
your definition of profit sure yeah sure
sure six teaspoons of sugar in a glass
of orange juice yeah
I remember as a kid adding sugar to it
as a little kid
we got this little tiny uh
I look like a little cold bin but you
know those little cute little things
like a little like a like something like
a little cold bucket that had like a
little spoon you know they have those
little cute little things you put sugar
butter in or whatever Coke yeah yeah
Coke yeah you could right now we have a
little uh like a little dinghy that has
a little paddle and the paddle is the
spoon adorable yeah sugar dish sugar
dish yeah
um yeah I used to put put sugar in it
oh
you're like a human onion you know
you smell like [ __ ] I don't like it make
me cry
uh all right let's see here this is from
Clark ten dollar homie here is it
garbage to ask the bartender wedding to
use their tip jar for change from a 20
bill
yeah you can't go into the tip jar yeah
people do people people step over that
line so so much
yeah stick your hand in the [ __ ] tip
jar what's wrong with you I get also if
you're there tip him with hit the hit em
with the 20 and then you're good make
sure you make the call attention do it
if you have to make eye contact as that
20 enters and then you're good all night
The Wedding we went to yeah last weekend
I went full Chrissy D route I did
everything Chrissy D said
the envelope was fat and when I got in
there I had a hundo walked up to the
lady at the bar I was like I'm gonna
give this to you now here's a handy
amazing service all night even when I
switch when when they switch bars from
the cocktail hour to inside the where
the reception was she was there and I
went to put another 20. she's like no no
my God you don't have to do that I put
the 20 in there I didn't get that once I
dunked about I dunked a hundo on it the
whole night you got to let her know I
was like what's your name I did I was
going hey hey Deborah Becky
stubsky right here I said make good with
the seven ounce Coors Light by the way
they were [ __ ] see you in three
minutes Jesus Christ was ordered two at
a time they were thimble's a beer she
was squeezing the lime in for me and
stirring my uh
uh tequil and Saudis because I don't
like the straw and I don't like having
the lemon right in there she was doing
herself good stirring it there you go
gotta take care of it we got to take
care of them because you get jammed up
there's like a you know 200 300 people
all going at one or two bars a lot which
they did a good job there was never
awaited to Bar the food was delicious
what steak was good yeah really came
together
um
I just once from the one and only Philly
take twenty dollar piece of trash here
you go first time question appreciate it
uh is a garbage dress in your old dirty
construction clothing while unemployed
so when you go to the liquor store when
it opens at 8 A.M you can pretend that
you just got off the night shift
I respect it I respect I gotta say the
thought level of that is I would love
for you to be like whoo long night you
know what I mean put some water in your
face
what time is it I gotta get the kids off
to school want something
[Music]
these nights are killing me say that
from the aisle
pretty soon I'll be on day shift just
put in my time you know but I think I
would do with that is I would change my
profession I wouldn't I would go doctor
or something like that go in there with
a doctor goes in with a lamp and the
stethoscope a pocket full of cotton
balls and tongue depressed that's what
I'd be doing man no no one does that
changing profession every couple of
weeks I think I'm gonna be a writer this
week but the Village People I'm an
Indian chief
let's go in there as a cowboy
I like it that's a good time
um this one's Aaron this one's like a
bit of a oxymoron I think is the word
is it garbage if as a kid your dad would
take you to free art galleries and tell
you to fill up on the hors d'oeuvres
because that's dinner man but trashy
move but Arc multiple art galleries
that's classy it is
dish I mean I've never
I don't think I've ever been to an art
gallery that's a Decepticon type of
trash those kind of dads my dad wouldn't
know he wouldn't know where in our
Gallery was if it if it landed on the
house
oh dude I remember my buddies my buddy's
family went to like a French restaurant
and I told my dad the eye roll could be
felt like he was even a French
restaurant he's like okay this plate
metal posters oh listen to Biz what are
they gonna thinking next remember when
you're a little kid you'd kill for
something like that I know now the
technology is caught up we're living in
the future you can get on this plate and
you get something cool like this they
got cool gaming stuff they got movies
they got cartoons and they got those
licensing deals with the big dogs Star
Wars Netflix whatever you're into they
got it's like literally millions of cold
as you go on there it's like the goddamn
encyclopedia it's fantastic uh they were
nice enough to send us we got one and we
got one hanging over by T-Bone uh if
they're awesome they're cool they're
easy pieces that go up they're sturdy
just pop baby they look different you
don't walk in you don't see four thumb
tacks hanging up a rip piece of paper
classy class it up a little bit we were
also still dirt bags because it's movie
references you know what I mean TV shows
and so we're not hanging up a Picasso
you know what I mean of course uh click
the link here I know click the link in
our description to see some of your
favorite displays and save up to 29 get
25 off when you buy one or two and 29
when you buy three or more holy crap
they're giving them away discounts will
automatically be applied to your car
when you click the link or use the code
Garbage When you visit display.com
that's displate.com code garbage or
click the link in our show notes do it
yep okay let's talk about ladder baby
ladder let's talk about taking care of
the family God forbid something happens
and it always does you don't want to put
this off you put off going to the
dentist you put off going to the DMV you
put off getting a haircut not this baby
get yourself some term life insurance
today no doctors no needles get up to
three million dollars in coverage you
don't got to see anybody you do it all
online it's absolutely fantastic and you
go to bed at night with the Peace of
Mind pay your loved ones are taken care
of yeah gang don't be a bozo get squared
away early on it's just a few minutes on
a phone or a laptop to apply louder
smarter algorithms work in real time so
you choose and find out if you're
instantly approved no hidden fees you
can cancel at any time get a full refund
if you change your mind in 30 days
because they're good people over there a
ladder ladder policies are issued by
insurers with long proven histories of
paying claims they're rated A and A Plus
by am's beds that's a lot of A's do it
finally since life insurance costs uh
more as you age Now's the Time to cross
it off your list so go to latterlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it now back to
that goddamn show back to the show we
ended up in a poetry reading one time on
a Friday night I can't remember whose it
was as a family yeah it was like a
cousins or something like that not a
cousin or like a friend of my my mom's
or something oh no oh man
we were dying laughing on the way home
just ripping this lady's life apart
doing the poems and stuff yikes that's a
tough look
yeah I don't think I've ever been to but
I get that however I can say this
again not to bring the wedding up again
but the hors d'oeuvres at the wedding
were phenomenal I could do just hors
d'oeuvres for dinner sure like a tray of
those puff whatever they are and some
scallops some bacon wrapped scallops
some this and that so I could see that
this weigh-in should be nice it's pretty
good
um all right let's see here ten dollar
homie uh Wendy
is it garbage to have collector plates
on a non-collector car example a 2002
Honda Accord
oh and it says collect like I guess yeah
how do you how are you allowed to do
that I don't think you are I'm assuming
because that's got to be like registered
and stuff right yeah although antique it
would say
antique collector historical I think is
one as well I think it depends on the
state to be honest with you
um because we have
my family's got a couple of dealer
plates
yeah we do what yeah throw a dealer
plate on it it's got magnets on it so
you can stick it on any car
[ __ ] you he believes in no time
let's go writing around Morocco with
Pennsylvania
I'm in my Chevy Lumina go around I'm
right I'm riding on two wheels like they
do in Dubai
would find you in three seconds yeah no
I'd have the full garb I would I would
love that I would realize I would love
to have people here I mean I think
people are after me anyway so if you
really set them off I'll be good
but yeah we got dealer plates which
which
how do you score them
you have to be registered as a dealer
like a weed dealer when did your family
own a car dealership get it obviously
yeah
um selling a car on the lawn yeah uh yes
he's throwing one of those uh dollar
bill win tunnels get a couple of hot
dogs on a donut tray yeah it might as
well be a used car lot sure yeah yeah
that's pretty good so we got that if
we're ever in a jam nice we can you know
then we got to go down there down where
we got to go down and get it from the
piece overnight express I don't know if
I'm waiting for the UPS man I'm hot
tailing it out of here dude she junk she
Jack compassed me the other day or not
the other day a couple months I needed
something overnighted
and I call her I'm like hey I didn't get
it yet and she's like it'll be there
Tuesday the overnight was 52.
and the two-day certified was only 14.99
I'm like gig I was paying it back the
money they're on a different level yeah
they're on it they're thinking different
levels they don't really I needed it now
I don't care what it costs you know what
a lot of people are doing now they sell
these uh we're gonna be four forever
they're taping uh leaves to their to the
yeah to the to the uh license plate
pretty sweet move I had my buddy uh
they're a bit uh my buddy and his
brother a little hippie dippy guys have
an Easy Pass first came out
they were going on a road trip from like
they were like going rock climbing and
like [ __ ] you know Maine or something
all the way up there so they had to
drive to like a bunch of States so
anytime an easy pass is coming they
would pull over and just put a t-shirt
there like tape a t-shirt drive through
for a mile or two to get out Shake It
Off yeah pretty good I was like I guess
yeah they're gonna you know this is way
back there was no real [ __ ] way of
catching either you know yeah
that'll send the state trooper over by
the way forgot about that had a little
running with a State Trooper out there
in Niagara Falls
New York stadium I believe I don't know
what he was we didn't talk a lot I
[ __ ] pulled you over on a horse
they don't have that angle of pursuit
really down pat
gotta close in on an angle like a D-Back
that's pretty yeah I got hemmed up
I was doing 80 in a 55.
Sammy Hagar what the hell
that's crazy yeah
yeah well you know
you might be driving next road trip I
might have got 18 points on my license
in that one fair enough
save that for the page I want to hear
all about that of course
um all right let's see this one we've
talked about a long time ago but a lot
of people they like upvoted themselves
or comment on it so I you know I wanted
to bring it back to light this was from
Alex uh
fresh 10 homie have you ever pulled an
empty popcorn bucket out of the trash at
the movie theater and taking it up to
concession stand for a free refill
I didn't even know they did free refill
they do on the largest largest of
everything you can get a free refill
okay well sodas are mostly
self-dispensing now no they mostly got
this not not everywhere and I gotta tell
you can I say can I say this no can I
say this
that Coke machine the self-dispensed one
sucks I don't know what it is it's not
great
and if they don't have regular Cherry
Coke as one of the buttons and they just
have regular Coke and then they have the
the the the little circles underneath
where you can pick it's not the same
juice it's not the same syrup it they're
not good mix yeah that's not good Toby
back me up on this the cocoa freestyle
machine suck ass I agree with you I
agree with you know where we were but
they're doing too much where did we stop
we were in where the [ __ ] were we were
in Kentucky or somewhere driving up from
Nashville to Indy and one of the stops
where we got where I got you the
soda that was all right though dude that
had oh that was like a [ __ ] Brewery
with the amount of spouts it was like a
30 [ __ ] individual that was Polar Pop
Polar Pop yeah that was that was free
refills too those animals were pulling
off remember that yeah the lady was
walking out holding them like that six
cops it was you buy the cup for a month
free refills and they were coming out of
the woodwork 6.99 for a month of sodas
so sure
um
yeah and then also I had one
in a styrofoam cup from The Waffle House
to go remember Casey B ran over that was
a styrofoam cup too that Diet Coke
yeah that's all right like the original
formula they used it was fantastic all
right
they've at the movies they've backed
away a little bit with the remember when
it used to be wax that covered the cup
the cups used to be covered in wax sure
that they were awesome that styrofoam
100 but what they're doing now it's
stupid the popcorn's still pretty good
I'll give you a heads up your ass as you
believe it they got to do something you
see that trick do you put the butter on
with the straw yeah get down to the
bottom you're not gonna believe this you
don't like the butter I'm not that big a
fan of that butter plus it's all over
you yeah it's all over you and I just I
can't go for it yeah you like leaving
room for all your other food to get all
over you well yeah I got my M M's that
I'm gonna put in the popcorn as I eat it
on top and then I usually have that kind
of serves as the moisture of or like the
the topping for the popcorn
if I had if I if there was a real butter
option I would coat that's real butter
no it's not kidding I would drown it in
that if it was real butter but I
whatever that is I'm not feeling that
how do you guys feel about the snow cap
only ever seen at the movie theater big
fan all right yeah I remember I
definitely go through phases where I get
they hit me up I get a box that like
hits me real nice they're always out
around Christmas somewhere like an
aunt's house well it's that is a small
version of what's referred to as a
non-preel which is a larger one big one
it's like it's like a half it's like a
quarter size yeah those things my Uncle
Mike loved them they have those in a lot
of like the loose candy places yeah they
do okay those come in a gift pack and a
gift bag for like the hollow or like a
gift basket for the holidays Joanne's
Nut House used to have the member of
Jones that house at the mall no ours was
we're not all nuts and I think it's
still open shout out to we're not all
nuts in Richboro Pennsylvania
I got a question for you fellas fire
away Toby as a kid were you ever allowed
to get the canned the loose candy in the
grocery store with this scoop yeah
that's what we're talking about that
didn't come out until they redid in the
grocery store yeah it came out they
redid our grocery store probably I was
in like junior high or like late that
came out uh yeah I would just like go
grab if I was with my Dad we could just
take a couple handfuls for the walk you
know what I mean we were checking out
with it uh just a little taste will do
you that might as well have been gold
bullion in my family I don't know
you're not paying for the packaging it's
in bulk they do that in Europe a lot or
from the week that I was there they did
a lot in France for the week you were in
that one city yeah
they did it at the movies in Paris it
was all Haribo stuff top shelf shout out
there but it was in a cone it was in
like a plastic cone it was weird
man a cookie over there I don't know
they know what they're doing with the
candy I could tell you that we weren't
allowed there was one place called
Snacks by the pound that we weren't
allowed to go in there it was also your
nickname
we go in there and hit that pretty hard
that's where I fell in love with the um
the Coca-Cola bottles the Haribo
Coca-Cola bottles
man
it doesn't give you quite enough to
satisfy you so you just keep going they
are something else
something else I tell you all right all
right moving on you're [ __ ] shove it
up over here in both instances uh this
one's from Matthew ever use Rubbermaid
container instead of a suitcase
[Laughter]
yikes
when I moved out onto my own I got my no
not moved out on my own when I got mine
I I moved out so I moved up here to my
buddy's house shout out Gooch I moved up
to gujar's apartments up on his floor
for a while and then a bed and then the
floor it was a whole whole scene but
when I moved out of there I moved in
when I moved I'm sleeping in the kitchen
at one point
um no I was based out of the kitchen
does that make sense because it was kind
of my my my you know forward operating
base it was a tight railroad kitchen at
the end of it it had like a breakfast
nook which was pretty nice it was like a
nice bench sure if for not for sleeping
you were sleeping like a half moon all
the time no yeah I so I kept my clothes
in there because when you lost the
weight that's where I went and got the
clothes when you gave me your old
clothes yeah so when I first lost all
the weight uh you came up and man
cleaned you out we were poor oh yeah as
a [ __ ] I needed those
I remember a pair of slacks and stuff I
told you the other day I think I texted
you when I was on my way to uh JFK I
said you remember I said do you remember
when I walked home when I did the
Laughing Skull festival and I walked
home from LaGuardia because I didn't
have bus money you heard that right he
walked like on the on-ramp like he
walked with the car I walked down the
Grand Central Grand Central Parkway or
yeah Grand Central Parkway I walked down
that
and how to like figure out how to get up
the retaining wall or whatever it was I
thought it'd be like 15 minutes it took
me four hours
dude I'm swear to God it took me four
hours that's also you flew without a
license without without photo ID for
some reason yeah I flew down there with
a wrinkled up uh
social security card and a
um
a credit card that I don't think was
mine
[Laughter]
was my mother
no it was my social insurance card or
something yeah it was an expired
insurance card yeah it was an expired
health insurance card
thanks you're all right
um all right let's see shout out to the
bozos and the homies uh this one's from
Big J doperson home runs name that's
great this just says living directly
next to a gas station question mark
as a young man it's convenient we live
next to one at the Titan house yeah roll
over there and get some snacks but we
didn't have we didn't have a straight
shot there was a fence trying to go out
we had to walk like a block to get there
take your bike in your hands too if
you're there running running low on
Bernie's whatever what it was [ __ ] or
if you're leaving for the night hit the
gas station grab the Bernies for the or
you're coming home stop and grab some
Doritos a Diet Coke a Gatorade for the
morning whatever it was it was all right
we would walk from there too we wear we
we would that we would we would leave
out of there into the city walking I
walked it every day to work I take the
bus yeah yeah I walked every day to and
from work
um yeah it it's not a lot that's a lot
for Philly
because if Philly's not like you're
really walking today you know they're
living in New York it's I mean it's like
it's probably like 15 blocks there's
like a yeah 15 minute Walker it ain't
nothing crazy damn Broad Street there
um shout out to we lived there Broad and
Wharton Luke oil I believe it was no
broadened Titan no Titan doesn't
intersect with broad oh we did a little
broad Awards the intersection was that
part of the street was around the corner
I'll be giving up our old addresses
either the Titan Street house that
turned into a comedy a Philly comedy out
I don't think there's any more the bees
are a little the bees live there uh a
couple other people
delcalo maybe I thought Lemaire lived
there I don't know a lot of people did
King Cobb
there you go
shout out to the boys
Philly doing all right not an on-time
rent payment in 10 years man those poor
bastards I wonder who was a sucker on
that lease
well it was me for a while with you in
the basement
because me and me Reggie and cotton
lived in a place in uh in Sunset Park
and another comedian friend of ours was
on the lease whoosh yikes if he was a
real friend he would have paid on time
and that drug him to the court system
you'll get it when we got it
and we don't have it
you're like splitting a baked potato to
three of us
um I just want some Chris ten dollar
homie here and everyone red is a garbage
to go to rehab with your dad
[Laughter]
both go kick it
yeah
that's tough booze I kind of get if
you're like if you're like a big boot
and you're like hey let's tighten this
up together I I can get that yeah if
you're doing hard drugs with your dad
bad luck but people have been there of
course I'm not judging I've definitely
done drugs with people's parents
for sure who's ever big on the drugs but
yeah I mean
sure
I did ketamine with my friend's dad in
the back seat of a Mercury Sable holy
[ __ ] got out to Columbus Ohio talking
about ripping lines like a gentleman
yeah maybe a bump of meth a weekend
warrior something
doing Kitty in the back of the Mercury
rare
that's a two-seater too isn't it that's
a two-door no I think it's a four-door
but I think it's one of the ones where
the seat goes up
oh it was that's a two-door oh two-door
yeah yeah it was a climber yeah
why are we in the back seat with them
they were jerking each other off what do
you mean I'm not gonna jerk a guy off in
a passenger seat was it his car no sure
wasn't
I don't know whose it was dude no one of
that dude no one in that story has a
driver's license let alone an insured
vehicle
wow
uh all right here let's see this is from
emmerich uh 20 homie uh lifelong bozo is
it garbage you have more than one shirt
with the county you live in
on it I have multiple Delco shirts Delco
I'll give you yeah because we're all
Philly dirt bags I respect felco's
famous don't go is kind of it's like
Orange County yeah delco's kind of
famous uh or at least you know notoriety
I mean all all it's always sunny I think
it has a bunch of or like they go to
Delco one time or something it's uh
don't go proper shout out to our boys
and uh Tommy POV and buttery and they're
bringing the whole gang
um so Delco definitely has some
clout some clout that's the word did you
see by the way I don't know if we talked
about it uh is The Bachelorette one of
the guys took the lady to Wildwood
really Pilgrim at a boardwalk down there
and they didn't even [ __ ] call to
consult me tell me they're operating my
backyard I'm the [ __ ] King of
the boards Daddio they go to Sam's at
least come and kiss the ring
uh no I don't know I didn't want it I
just saw a clip and then everybody
started tagging me he's like you believe
this [ __ ] he didn't win he did I think
he got voted off right then on mori's
pier
laughs
girl she doesn't want you anymore
uh all right let's Bank through a couple
of Mo here let's get we got a lot of
first timers let's get those first
timers out though there you go
um
this one I'm not even sure this is from
Matt uh ten dollar homie is a garbage to
Bar your front and back doors shut with
old shower rods so we are safe no I'm
all about it I guess the doors don't
lock because I asked you that question a
couple weeks ago I said you've ever
slept with it with a
a chair up against the door yeah that
was a chair but I remember I've done
like stuff around the windows and stuff
like that for sure I'm all about that
the Foley house is like that yeah that
has
security measures we'll say
crazies like home alone too yeah um you
know what I'm a big fan of the rod and
the windows in the window the the window
slides that way put a little metal rod
in there in in the stopper yep I forget
I forget what house it was
one of my dad's one of the houses I was
in with my dad
the sliding back door to get onto the
patio we used a [ __ ] hockey stick
yeah yeah I took the blade off it was
like one of those cheap wooden ones took
the blade off [ __ ] hacked solid it
down took the front gate of a castle
ah yeah shut that down you put the stick
in mm-hmm oh yeah put the bar down is
what what they would say at Miami my
brother hit each other with it and [ __ ]
oh yeah put the bar down and shut up and
close the curtains nobody peeking in put
your valuables in your [ __ ] go to bed
yeah
like a normal person
they don't do it anymore but when I was
a kid the value of the the family
whatever Jewels for lack of a better
word they they the heirlooms yeah they
they move you inheriting anything like
of of value you think uh I have like did
your does your parents estate have any
commemorative plates coins Jewels well
you know going up in value yeah my my
dad passed a few weeks ago as you know
and uh yeah and um I have uh 50 of a
railroad and that I got [ __ ] anything
the camera yeah it's an idiot
am I inheriting anything now obviously I
know not of money I guess I get 15
minutes in the garage
grab what you can and keep it moving tar
all over your body Patty says otherwise
it's getting thrown out no I just meant
like get rid of it is there any like a
set of earrings like there's some
there's something of significant that
your mom had a necklace uh that's just
yeah I know she has some set of 911
earrings or something she's got she's
got some sort of national tragedy
jewelry
I didn't mean money I know I know you
guys are poor poor bastards 9 11 here
doesn't she you saw The Ring what ring
but the ring that I had this weekend
that was my Dad's ring we each got one
of my dad's Rings you had one of your by
the way it barely fit on your pinky now
yeah it was uh that was a tight squeeze
I'm a larger man but he was a bigger guy
too but it was from younger as younger
days no he wore it up and he wore it on
his uh he got it on there yeah
yeah it's good yeah I'm a fat piece of
[ __ ] I'm not hey I didn't say that I
just said yeah just that okay there's
harmonica for my grandfather's but it
doesn't really work
it's out of tune your real attitude
every time I play it the deer come up to
the backyard
a bunch of Mallards start circling the
house
the dog shits himself I don't think we
have every time I play Blues Traveler
but we never had anything of significant
value no there's uh there's some
Waterford Crystal I think she got when
she got married to my dad everybody has
that yeah I don't think there's anything
of actual significance nothing like that
nothing yeah no Shore House no nothing
like that I'll get the shore house there
you go I'll have to fight my brother in
court for that'll be a knockdown drag
out battle
I can't wait till we all see each other
in whatever Court look at Atlantic
County Court Cape May County Courthouse
I've been in there before
hammed up
um
nah I got nothing you got anything like
that your family I could see that I
could see your mom having I've been like
animals heirloomy like oh they do have a
painting or a whatever or something
pretty nice martini shaker there you go
it's Bedazzled only been used 8 000
times
the inside's all worn away now I'm sure
your mom's a classy lady I'm sure she
has some some painting some artwork some
furniture stuff like that
you know what she has she has a giant
Julia Child Jack papan poster
autographed that's pretty sweet that's
not bad I wonder what that goes for yeah
I wonder how much that original cookbook
goes the the original Julia Child's
cookbook
I don't know we might have I always
confused her with Julia Roberts
not even joking I gotta do like that
that equation in my head she wasn't a
pretty woman
shout out to Julia Childs
I love doing Ocean's 13. her husband was
in the come work for the company
supposedly
work for the OSS World War II may or may
not have been uh associated with a
certain organization
Virginia okay
familiar with their operation you act
like you have Insider scoop on this why
are you whispering to hundreds of
thousands of people
don't tell anybody but I think I'm an
idiot
I saw Julian Julia
the movie Tucci was in it that Meryl
streepman she's something else in that
she's great you ever see that Julie and
Julia
good movie
Saul Kramer versus Kramer so did I we
watch that in a health class we were
talking about divorce that's the first
time I saw a set of knockers when he was
nailing that broad I don't remember they
didn't show us that part
oh yeah Dustin Hoffman started banging
some chick and the kid came out in the
middle of the night she was walking down
the hallway Buck Naked the first time I
saw a naked woman
I never looked I can't push her for my
dad to get a divorce after that
I get divorced bring some broads over
here
Spruce the place up a little bit huh
well it might be cat what's a deal uh
two Christmases and two nice sets
what'd you what was the second Christmas
is it two nights at DTS
pretty good
let's start breastfeeding again huh
it's [ __ ] up it's a classy program
here and I get off the Dewey's
laughs
now back to looting our parents house
I don't think I don't think there's
anything of value in my parents house
I'll tell you this is pretty true TV's
from like 2022. you might know dude our
TV downstairs legit is pre-911. and it
works like it's 911 TV yeah I don't know
I don't know how it works but it works
it it they must have put smart
technology in this back in the like way
back in the day anticipating the day
that all this stuff would come together
because you can get a Sleeper Cell TV
sitting around waiting to be activated
like the goddamn Manchurian Candidate
I'm never going to that house again
transforms in the middle of the night
stabs us
now because you could get Netflix and
stuff on it and you shouldn't I'll tell
you things would have gone different if
that TV had been on that plane
we're not going anywhere
uh we do this which is pretty trashy
um which you might know is we have a set
of Foley Estate wine glasses I saw yeah
that's in that's yeah I feel like those
are in the patreon heavy but that's it
those are the good wine glasses
they're the good ones I don't even think
we have good ours are ours is like the
Mateen the martini shaker it's like
they're getting no cycling through
quickly and they break a lot of it we
have a lot of stuff we have a lot of
stuff in the house that the Foley name
is on that we are not affiliated with
yeah yeah
yeah and if we drive by a place that
says Foley's we're all getting out of
the car and taking a picture sure
kidney
um anybody asked me on three bars and uh
County Cork
[Laughter]
is sheep farm ours I I would tell you uh
it's not trashy we are so it was with my
mom my mama got remarried and my dad my
stepdad moved into the house they were
together for a long time before but it
was like you know this official like my
mom's changed her name
um
and to Kelly was there you know her new
married name so they got embroidered tap
embroidered hand towels for the powder
room with K on them for Kelly
and we're so dumb
me my brother and my sister all thought
it was for Kevin the K like we didn't
realize that you put your last name on
hand towels like that's what rich people
do so my brother this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's got towels with his
initials on him
let me get a hoodie it almost created
world war three dude my mom's like it's
our last it's my new last name we're
like okay I always thought we never
never had anything like that when I was
a kid this was no but this was two I
mean this was probably 2005. we would
maybe have a uh an outdoor mat that
would say Patty and Terry or something
like that that's to us was like we had
where I don't even know where to get
those made our cousin made them one year
because she was doing like it's just old
pieces of garbage she was doing like
painting and she made them as like one
of the family Christmas gifts but going
over to people's houses two things the
embroidered
um hand towels and stuff like that like
nice nice white fluffy towels well we
only had them in the powder room on the
first floor in case people come over to
look like they were using [ __ ] shop
you know we were using shop rags and
[ __ ] Gojo Angela pink orange hang
cleaner like we were goddamn mechanics
washing your hair with lava at 11 years
old yeah yeah that pum is getting in
your eyes God damn it I loved that stuff
oh nothing reminds you of a hard day of
work and [ __ ] cleaning your hands off
with that [ __ ] your hands would be
cracking but you know the white and blue
the white tote bag with the blue bottom
yeah that would have like a k or an f on
it yeah it would that would be the first
middle initial man when I was a kid I
was like someday
I still look at those I think that the
brand that they are is very expensive it
is I don't know what it is I was always
in the back of like a nice uh like a
Mercedes-Benz like some rich chick that
you always High School rich girls had
them yeah yeah and I'm like where you
just got money laying around to do that
yeah crazy crazy I remember one time I
found out my buddy my buddy's family was
getting their dry cleaning dropped off
picked up and dropped off like in the
bird delivered because I walked up and
there was a bag of clothes on the front
door and I walked like I walked in the
house I'm like yo bag of [ __ ] there's
some homeless guy yeah I don't know put
that that's the dry cleaners coming to
pick that up I was like okay I'm gonna
see myself out I don't belong here no
more yeah real new money I felt like a
[ __ ] idiot
I didn't even know that was possible in
The Burbs
took a lot to use the dry cleaners at my
house my dad would have to get his
uniforms uh dry cleaned no my dad would
dry clean not even [ __ ] around his
jeans jean shorts crazy go get a mean
crease put in them
straight down that butter with those yes
his jeans and his jean shorts go I gotta
go pick up my jeans shirt I gotta go
pick up my shorts [ __ ] come out
because they were like [ __ ] they were
like a there was like four pair of you
know I would probably say 1988
501 Levi's
like the original four pan like they
were the first full pairs ever come off
the line
crimped up real nice when my uncle
passed away I got a majority of his
clothes and he had he was he was a
businessman he had so many button-down
shirts that I wore but the first time
that I wore them was brutal because he
would they were all dry clean I got like
from the dry cleaner heavy starch dude I
remember wearing them and like I would
have like cuts on my neck after wearing
them for a couple hours you turn your
head you almost slit your carotid artery
yeah yeah those things are tough dude
need a couple of couple of fabric
softeners loosen those up a little bit
I'm gonna [ __ ] fluff cycle will you
work I got a hot date tonight uh we
gotta wrap it up gang gang we love yous
we love yous come out and see us on the
road there
a couple of things coming up it's going
to be really fun couple things coming up
uh uh Atlanta by this point might be
sold out Charlotte still has some
tickets left get those if you're in the
North Carolina I think that's on the
border right yeah if like that's North
Carolina South carolina-ish or wherever
come see us in Charlotte pick up tickets
to that second Boston show at it that's
gonna that might even be gone by the
time this comes out and Providence uh
pick those tickets up Philly sold out uh
the card game is on sale as you hear
this get those wild supplies last we're
doing one last run of the original deck
of cards this bad boy right here Toby
hit me it's like over I think it's like
53 or 52 of our favorite original
questions of the [ __ ] of ayg so
that'll be doing one last one of them
get those as well follow us on Insta the
whole nine yards check out the chip the
clip Channel new guy Luke is out there
banging away on the clip channel do it
all baby activate the are you garbage
activating are you garbage Army we love
you we'll see you next week peace